hãy phải hãy phát hiện xây chờ, tôi này được sự quan đất rất đặt biệt.
Bộ học xây.
Hãy phát hiện xây chờ vôm hai bộ phát jế, là phân cạnh phá phần lưỡng.
Phân cạnh là phân tạo ra từ chường.
Bộ là nằm chờ.
Phân lưỡng, là phân tạo ra vòng liệt.
Bộ nả khu vầy.
Bộ hãy phát, thì còn có bộ phật đó là 2 cái phành quên và 2 cái chủ quế,
giúp để lưỡng giống niệm là mạnh quá.
Bộ mấy phát hiện là dựa trên hiện ở cạnh phận.
Nếu dựa sẽ gầu là, bộ mấy phát hiện là dựa trên hiện ở cạnh phận.
Bộ phát nào lưỡng ím thì có ina xíc tạo.
Bộ phát nào truyền đặc thì hỏi nả, rô đau.
Như trên hiện bây, thì không dây truyền đặc.
Bây không dây lúc này là phần ứng hỏi nả, rô đau.
Bây nó trên ứng hỏi nả, rô đau.